this is this is this is it this is yeah
you go to indonesia with this these are
thirty-five thousand beasts in indonesia
you're going to jail for so long yeah
you got like 20 years yeah just give
them to the people at the police station
take these they're vitamins
those little chinese people go down in
[ __ ] flames in indonesia
we ready we're ready this podcast is
brought to you by
hellotushy.com bidets are back [ __ ]
portable days that fit right in your
bathroom and they work magnificently
deal with it [ __ ] let me
explain something to you it's father's
day i know you've looked at your dad
from time to time and said you know what
i could tell my dad's [ __ ] stinks
look at your dad and you go he's had
those pants on for three days he's a
filthy animal
but i can't say none because he's my dad
but you know what his ass home will
smell like you know why him and your mom
sleep in separate beds
because he's a filthy [ __ ] animal but
let me explain something to your
father's day is coming and you could
send them a hello tushy right to his
door go to hellotushy.com and take a
look at those portable
bidets you're going to love them you got
a 90-day money-back guarantee what does
it do it washes your [ __ ] what do you
mean i put anything portable portable
you put it on any toilet that you want
it connects to the to the tubing and the
next thing you know after you take a
little poop you know let's say you're
feeling down and you want a little
sprinkle in your [ __ ] you sit down
you turn it on and it washes your little
muffler for you just like they do in
japan the only thing is this is portable
go to hellotushy.com right now and press
in church bam and get memphis
your order delivered right to your house
also the podcast is brought to you by
audit
on it the leader in supplements whether
it's alpha brain shroom tech or shroom
tech sport go to onyx.com right now and
press in church bam
and get 10 percent off also
thank you for listening to the church
kick that mule lee
monday june 12th you filthy [ __ ]
animals
get up
it's over you're going to war
the koreans are light in the dutch let's
do this [ __ ]
oh yes you do
the church of what's happening now
lee siyat
ari shafir
and your uncle joey
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
welcome to podcastville uncle joey here
welcoming you on a beautiful monday
morning slinging dick and giving out
chopsticks
lisa ayat's here i think kari shafi is
here i'm here i'm mostly here i'm mostly
here that was a tremendous bung i told
you yeah this new weed we're getting out
here this new weed from the one-eyed jew
jesus this is killing [ __ ]
sorry i tried to send you postcards to
warn you i didn't get to that don't come
back too strong now nobody went out the
intelligence [ __ ] but you went away for
a long time
with shiny shoes no more it's weird you
smoked out there you would have laughed
at it it was that it's all brown oh yeah
it's just like sticks of things
seeds oh yeah there's so many seeds what
do they charge depends where some place
is not much like 10 bucks for like
like a ground up eighth you know like a
shitty looking eighth yeah maybe where'd
you get the best weed at
vietnam vietnam vietnam had good wii uh
yeah one guy had it
like california weed or vietnam it'd
been a long time it had been like two
and a half months already so
just way better than anything i remember
how was the food in vietnam pretty good
those bambi sandwiches
you would
just quick [ __ ] in a little bun
like uh like an eight incher
they stuff it they it's like just fresh
super fresh bread like real they got
that from the french and the french
invaded them and they just stuff it full
of [ __ ] like what
chicken and then like uh like a little
long carrot
and some like hot peppers in there if
you want
a little bit of it's just their own like
you know hoagy i guess who invaded
vietnam first french french the french
got out and then immediately america is
like hell yes we're getting in there
because if you watch apocalypse now the
redux yeah they add those scenes what's
inside where they're having dinner at
the french house and they get into an
argument and the guy tells me the french
are already gone
you know what or the french was part of
the house the french it's the french's
house
this is the scene after they go and surf
charlie don't surf and then they go to
the thing and they see the playmates
come down the helicopter
from there they go on to the lagoon
and they go somewhere
and the movie turns the turn you know
the apocalypse now
when it came out in 79 it was a great
cut it was a three and a half hour movie
yeah but then for the 20th anniversary
or something i don't know exactly
they added that extra hour and a half
hour and a half some five hours
something something if you want to look
it up lee
and there's a scene where they're in
some guy that's french soldiers and
they're having dinner
and they get into an argument and they
explain to the american that you know
you can't we can't believe what you're
doing now that we already dealt with
this so that's now yeah i forget all
yeah they had like two successive wars
there
the french and they drove off the french
and then immediately americans moved in
they're like we're gonna take you over
they never attacked anybody they just
they were just there
they called the american war there and
how does vietnam look today
it's all right
ho chi minh was pretty packed pretty
packed yeah motorcycles everywhere it
takes you like 20 minutes to work up the
course across the street
they just go there's so many of them
hundreds of them
yeah i know over overdone like like they
just keep they have districts to go out
farther and farther they'll be because
you [ __ ] you american no not once they
like us now they like us now that was
just an old government they don't care
about them well are you they don't like
the chinese anymore are you south uh
korean or vietnamese or am i of korean
or vietnamese descent no you just asked
me i just uh is it were you in south or
what should we what i'm sorry i'm even
vietnam sorry jesus christ that's how
what was your question for a second i
was confusing korea with vietnam did you
think i was korean or vietnamese yes no
no no i thought you i thought you were
in uh korea not vietnam oh i got it i
got it what did you find out about
apocalypse now 450. that's what it
finished with four hours 50 minutes yeah
for the redux godly that's so long
yeah you can't come on you can't do that
no i can't i can't do it i've never i've
watched parts of the redux i can't lie
to anybody i've watched parts of it it's
just too long yeah and i think it takes
you somewhere you don't want to go
they've redone the godfather they've
added all the scenes back
really like [ __ ] nine hours
all three of them together all three of
them together you see them in
chronological order you see that no no i
think it's the first two and they put
all the parts back
and it comes out if you if it starts at
12
it goes till six or seven o'clock at
night hbo oh and now i think bobby
didn't bobby put something out today on
facebook bobby sharon
they're releasing the godfather for a
week
what do you mean in theaters yeah oh the
next week or the week after oh
re-releasing the godfather for a week
for the 45th anniversary i think that's
gonna be the move i think you know what
do you know why you know why because of
godfather four because they're trying to
present pre-hype for it really yeah
they're trying to get people talking
about godfather four yeah are they gonna
shoot a gunfight yeah yeah yeah it's
like the
grandson or something
or like damn in like a war with somebody
else i don't know
i mean i think this maybe it's a son
maybe it was that kid maybe the kid grew
up the boy a dumb boy yeah yeah what if
the dummy got gotten like
gotten head of the mafia seems like a
comedy then right
i guess that's slow-weighted son
if he became the head of the mafia it
always happens
i thought for a while that they could i
think the movie theaters could survive
on just re-releasing
the best of the old movies and then and
just
i mean there are movie theaters that
show old movies but if you just
re-release like the best not every movie
but just had like a summon summer yeah
and you could do and you could do uh
like marathons like if you wanted to do
the all the godfathers in one row yeah
dude but just give the new movies a
break until they get a chance to make
listen there's people that are nostalgic
about a lot of movies so what you do is
16 candles yeah
ferris bueller let's get ferris bueller
yeah sure okay ferris bueller everybody
loves ferris bueller you want to
re-release ferris bueller you'll get my
seven dollars but i'd rather you add two
or three things
you know two or three scenes that we
didn't see oh yeah something and we
release it on the 32nd anniversary and
i'll pay you the [ __ ] 12 or whatever
the [ __ ] it is sorry yeah i'm just
saying that i don't mind those are my
favorite movies i mean everybody's
nostalgic about 16 candles or
what's the other one it is 16 candles
with the chinese guy
yeah they adopt the chinese guy
you steal her underwear yes he steals
the underwear that's a good one shows it
off we're michael hall that's right
that's like he had the party
yeah yeah yeah he's under the thing
all those movies are phenomenal
you know the breakfast club was just on
what did i watch today
today i watched the second half of
something that i said this never [ __ ]
comes on
you know those movies if there's nothing
to do yeah
now let me explain something to you
there's some people who like going to
tarantino steve the beverly oh yeah
would you let me ask you something lee
because you actually go to more movies
than myself and ari yeah for sure right
i used to
would you go see
one of your favorite old movies with
paula at the at the uh starlight this is
the skylight arclight
and pay the eighteen dollars yeah i
wouldn't pay eighteen but here's the
thing how much is the arc light i i
think arcload's around that i think oh
fifty thirteen fifteen fifteen something
like that let's pretend now i'm not even
talking about the godfather let's be
fair
let's say uh here's an example just for
kids my age like we we watched good
burger a few months ago had a way better
time like that
and and and that's not a classic for
like a good burger really but it's a
classic for like stoner like just for
like but i think you could get away
going from like the 70s and 80s even not
even not even the 90s you could do the
90s if you wanted to but your 70s and
80s and just because how you always get
off get up mad at me for like not seeing
things
like give us a chance to see it and then
because the only reason tickets are that
high is because of these [ __ ] these uh
whatever it's called the uh studios are
making that's where they make their
money so if they just re-released old
movies they could lower ticket prices
because they're not paying anything to
get the movies out there
so they probably end up making more
money
because they're not that all they have
to do is pay residuals i would like to
open up a movie theater i would do it
differently like i went to a movie
theater in san francisco in 1985 ari
that he would have died yeah
they closed it up or maybe it's still
open it's on the tenderloin it's on the
it's on haydashbury i'm sorry and it
used to be close to the end and i saw a
mask there
the movie
hair and the little kid not the mask oh
sorry mask 1985 with cher
when she had the kid that was really
ugly with the [ __ ] up head you ever
see that no what a default mask yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah eric roberts eric
rob so what i had to do was this movie
theater
i don't know how they made money but
this is the deal guys he had a big head
in that movie yeah it was real and in
real life it was even bigger and he died
this summer and [ __ ] did he really yeah
he died that summer eric roberts no the
guy that [ __ ] eric roberts [ __ ]
played
oh this is what they had this is why i
don't know if you can make money or be
successful
first of all you'd have to put love
seats
because people go in twos go wearing
twos to the movie theater
okay so at this movie theater that i
went to san francisco oh yeah in 85 yeah
they just had
23-man couches that looked like
the couches in la jolla oh really all
[ __ ] busted and whatever they redid
them
real cool yeah they had ashtrays in
there for weed and cigarettes
they made popcorn with real butter all
right and they made homemade chocolate
chip cookies not the [ __ ]
uh like a guy was there
packing the clothes
yeah wow and they would come out and the
bell would ring like that
nice
it would still look like 1950 in there
you could still smell the sperm from the
burlesque days but it didn't matter you
sat in the couch you could take your
shoes off really pop your legs across
the [ __ ] thing
you could let's say just you and i went
well let's say you and your girlfriend
went in the afternoon yeah and there was
nobody there you could sit on the couch
and spread your legs
so your feet are touching and watch the
movie you need popcorn just like you
were at your house wow
so that's the experience i want to
provide the only problem is if you have
those type of couches
how many people can you put in there in
one shot right well uh cuts
there's a chain called ipic which my dad
goes to in florida all the time they
have servers which are very nice they
have they give everyone blankets and
reclining chairs and you have a server
that will come to your chair during the
movie theater in toronto they had that
20 years ago
it's amazing well they would come up to
you that seats would recline
and there'd be a little table next to
you and she would come give you beers
chocolate shakes
i would [ __ ] pay to go to a movie
theater and get a chocolate shake thin
yeah yeah think about that think about
that one on sunset has stuff like that
they have a tomato bisque
tomato soup and they have a little
buzzard goes off listen the [ __ ]
island has the chicken sausage really
with the sandwich it's brilliant it
comes to your seat
uh no waitress is that yours that sucks
dick yeah did you go to the movies when
you were overseas yeah yeah one time
where did you go i went uh to uh in uh
in uh yangon
myanmar i went to the assassin's creed
a couple australian girls so where did
the tour start when did your get your
head together to a star that i might get
to have
that's what i call it people say where's
our reason to get your head together too
yeah
i started myanmar i went there first
then they [ __ ] around myanmar when was
the flight
i don't know like
13 to 20 hours you slept a whole flight
i slept some of it for sure i i don't
think i don't remember having any
edibles
no i do because i had some i had some in
myanmar
i found one so i i had him on the plane
so yeah that was it though
on the plane there for the first half
then you get the guitar you got to
transfer guitar and i don't want to
[ __ ] have anything there
where's guitar
doha or doha is a city it's hard
somewhere in the middle east it's a
country that just got like no one in the
middle east is
like acknowledging them anymore really
why i don't know
it's weird but what like how did it even
pick i don't i don't even know where
myanmar like i would never even be able
to pick it up southeast asia it's just a
country in southeast asia it's [ __ ]
cool man where did you live there you
went to hostels went to hostels one
night at a hotel then straight to
hostels [ __ ] met people there they
told me where else to go
you know what the other cities are
within the place people they're
recognizing you right away none right
away none
that was cool
i think it was like i think it was like
uh
it was like the first time
yeah i think like [ __ ] i don't know
two weeks in two and a half weeks in
something like that
and then somebody was which is fine it
was cool
and then like less and less
you know
yeah then none again until like i don't
know i don't know yeah it's it was like
three or four or five times total so you
over there for 90 days cambodia you've
been with it for 90 days yeah 100 100
and
10567 days
how long do you got a little
clarity i have to like a good question
after like uh maybe a few weeks
pretty quick you just start like uh just
thinking all the time you know what
point there's no [ __ ] to do were you in
a lake soaking your feet
in edinburgh in scotland being on
mushrooms up in the hills just walking
around when the sun comes up
and just having like moments of like oh
i get it okay i can do it this way
okay i can just do it this way just
figuring it all out
yeah real clarity
but uh
i don't know if i had any there no i did
sometimes yeah i went to some [ __ ]
uh monastery some buddhist monastery
like duncan
and you just have to meditate all day
you're supposed to clear your head have
no thoughts whatsoever
and did you do it no i had so many
thoughts
how long did you have more than i've
ever heard did you sit down for it well
that's what happens do all that yeah it
just floods in you're supposed to like
learn how to like i guess get him to go
away but man it makes you think about so
much stuff
and like five four or five days of that
you're just like oh did you stay there
for four or five days yeah yeah these
little [ __ ] yoga mats
where'd you sleep on the floor wood
floor on a yoga mat
and would you eat
um protein-less food
you can't kill animals or insects
you know those [ __ ] spiders
right in your [ __ ]
bunk
you're not supposed to kill it for a
while so you have to like
just let a giant spider to be nearby
yeah
but yeah they don't eat animal at all so
like you eat like a bunch of cabbage
based foods
um rice
yeah they had they had one hard shower
that was cold and they had one trickle
but it was pretty hot
so it really was like uh which way we're
gonna go defense if you got it midday
when it was hot out okay maybe you'll
risk the
the freezing cold i don't know how it
got that cold though
man
uh
or the trickle and you just gotta like
you know sort of save it up in your palm
at one point when you were over there
were you ready for the united states at
one point you never really were were you
no i'd still be out there yeah you still
yeah i'd still be out there
yeah i was starting to have i really
if i was a betting man
i didn't think you were gonna come back
to about june yeah i was hoping you
wouldn't come back
even though i missed you yeah i knew
where you were at you know
in 1989 which i was in 1982 i was a
young since 83 i was a young kid
and
those five years were just brutal and i
never forget just getting in the car
driving to aspen yeah and the first week
i just slept
until this day i think of that unwinding
at that time in my life and i thought
about what you were doing
at the age of 40. one day you said
that's it
yeah that's it i don't want to take
these questions
yeah
i understood exactly
from every aspect the more i thought
about it because what else was going on
here was then gabriel tapped out what
did what do you mean gabriel gabriel
called his agents one day and said i'm
done what do you mean i'm not doing this
no more he took a four-month sabbatical
just left
just no he didn't leave he just said
for a little while didn't talk to
agencies or managers yeah canceled two
or three tours and now
he just recently went back he did a
couple weekends and he's doing the
european tour he's got no other day i
feel like if you ease your way back in
that's okay
get loose again because you like about
some normal stuff you left in my january
oh you filled up my dates what's that
you filled up my dates i don't know when
i left that's funny because when you
left
like i went to work on the sixth yeah
like i did a one one-nighter with steve
simon january january 6th okay yeah
and then that weekend the following
weekend i was
home and then for three weekends in a
row i worked and i had to shoot a pilot
for animal planet and i'm getting calls
about the numbers and i'm getting calls
about the podcast and everybody's
sending you [ __ ] emails to give you
uh scripts about the [ __ ] podcast and
i mean it was like three weeks from hell
and i sat there for a minute and i go
you know i understand
where aries at now
i understand you know and it's
it's really weird how in this life it's
better to want
you to have it's
sometimes you think about something you
don't think of how much work you're
gonna have to put into this
and it really
[ __ ] blows you away like
how much [ __ ] you take yeah for trying
to do something good yeah sometimes like
leave me alone for a minute let me just
leave me alone for a minute let me
[ __ ]
get out something good you know how
those bloggers suck because they have to
put out some every single week instead
of waiting until something they really
actually care about
yeah you're gonna be that
it just gets so
and i'm not whining here and i'm not
saying but this happens to everybody in
life i'm just fortunate that ari
recognized it and said you know what
[ __ ] all you [ __ ]
suck at dick [ __ ] it's over i'm not
doing it it's over and a lot of people
in regular lives listen you got some
money put away
you know you're thinking about your
retirement but life gets hectic
sometimes what are you gonna do wait do
you have a heart attack you know what
yeah why not get out and see the [ __ ]
world
and see the world that's why you work
yeah that's why you do all this [ __ ]
that you do you think if i had a
passport get out of here if i had a
passport i would take a trip every 90
days with my wife and my job did you see
these old people out there oh yeah the
old couple that are going out there and
then our tour going from thing to thing
but they're like 75 and it's like
they're not gonna really have a good
time they're just gonna see it and go
home
they're not gonna go to some [ __ ]
party somewhere
well just think about it any day like i
say on stage any day after 50
you know when you're [ __ ] 50 yeah
you might die any day yeah oh jesus you
know what i'm saying that's the truth
that's a reality yeah you hit 50 whippy
everybody goes home
you take your birthday gifts upstairs
it's the way down and then five days
five years you're getting a discount at
denny's
at 55 next year i got a discounted debt
what that's it it's over and then i got
10 more years of work after that and
then whatever
you start next year you get an old
person discount i get a discounted
denny's not even not only that i can
also apply for my pension from sag
really i could get a [ __ ] early
pension are you going to [ __ ] sure no
why because you never know what could
happen what if [ __ ] uh you get a show
and you need to or for your uncle to be
on there there i am so what you were
doing they force you to retire no you
can't get a pension then go back in the
in the game well maybe but why take a
chance why take it leave it in there i
don't need it right now oh okay yeah
what about i got it
what am i gonna get two grandfathers no
no it's good it's like a [ __ ] time
i'm saying i could steal two grand yeah
don't say that no no you know what i'm
saying two grand twenty two hundred i
think social security does it go up does
it go up yeah it goes up over the years
you book a big movie or something you
get a couple extra points plus you get
social security plus i get after what's
after gonna give me the combined now 350
and combine now i know but what are they
going to give me 350 a month maybe you
know what it all adds up they're going
to get a lot yeah it's all adds up when
you're 65. do the [ __ ] carpet later
man broke like everybody else 65. you
know what i'm saying then then sag has a
house right up here remember that they
used to have an old age home yeah
right in the uh
old actors
yeah
you didn't know that no woodland hills
you could go to the doctor in woodland
hills hold alone actors
yeah right now go to sag
and they have locations and there's a
location
up here somewhere
up here right up in the valley where you
go they have every movie ever made and
they just put them they have a gym they
have a health center oh a gym like
heated pool
steam batch the whole [ __ ] thing and
then they have a village there
and it's for older sag members who have
no family and they feed you they have a
doctor on on
staff up there yeah every night you can
meet and watch movies different old
people that are there the actors talking
about experiences they had it's pretty
[ __ ] cool because they cost some
money jack and comes out of their stuff
they wanted to be center of his
attention and you have to
and now know yourself listen to them
what do you mean like when they were
actors they were like all about like
look at me
you know fees are based solely on the
ability to pay so you like it it's
expensive for rich people but i think
yeah where is it at woolen hills yeah
woolen hill they're based on the
absolutely [ __ ] beautiful
discount if you don't have much money
yeah i think that's what i mean when i
was signing up woodland hills that's
pretty close i was signing up to be in
the editors union right before i went
did this full time and they said big
shift in your life
and they said that they had some it
wasn't a house but they like there's a
fund
for like people in hollywood who go on
hard time like you have to apply to it
really yeah
i know yeah and it's uh i guess it's
kind of cool yeah they steal that fun
don't believe the hype that's fun don't
do dick for you you for to get that fun
you got to do 18 hours of paperwork
they want paperwork from you from the
old country israel forget it by the time
you get the check you'll [ __ ] be dead
they send me those things every year
donate to the actor's fund i ain't
donating dick because i know you're not
going to help no [ __ ] actors for you
to get you when you if you check listen
if you get a residual check lee you
ready for this one sit down tightly you
ready i'm saying if you get a residual
check okay right and let's say you have
a family of three and it's a check for
like two thousand dollars
and you don't get it within 30 days
guess how long
first off let's say for a fact sag
scented
june
13th which is tomorrow morning
it should get to your house by thursday
correct if they send it from warship
boulevard sure now if you call sag in 10
days and go listen i haven't got it yet
you guys sent me a check you know what
they tell you what you got to wait 30
days why
and then file a report oh for a claim
guess how long it takes you to get your
your residual check how long six months
which is your money
it's your [ __ ] money it takes that
long just six months to get that check
yeah that your family [ __ ] follow up
on over and over and over follow up call
them see if they've got processed they
found your euro check one time they had
a check for five months their shitty
union that one time they had it they
didn't could they i was waiting for a
check five months you know i got a call
one day out of the random and they go
hey man
we found a check for you here at sag it
was returned
yeah one checkers in there like it's for
like eleven hundred dollars i'll be
there in three minutes
i cut everybody off on the way to
[ __ ] they were closing at five it
was like 20 to five
and they found that check that was
missing really then i put the [ __ ] oh
drop behind something
like they did something stupid with it
yeah
they said that they got it you know you
don't know how many times
your call after has an account
that you could go on there you go to
your after account
and you can go and claim checks that
you'll you'll die
you'll die
you'll die
you'll go
how come i never got this check
i lived there
yeah when you sent it and all of a
sudden you look at the address and they
send it to you at the comedy store
and you're like why would you do
something like it's
it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous when you go on that file
go on it yeah take some time get high go
to after and look for missing checks
look print up your name they got three
of your checks
guarantee they got three checks for
about a thousand thirteen hundred bucks
that they could is that they've been
sending checks to your address for 20
years to the wrong address no they've
been sending you checks like you still
get checks from after but for one reason
or another yeah they got a [ __ ] brain
fart on that day and sent it somewhere
when you look at the address go
i've never lived in [ __ ] ohio yeah
like they they do [ __ ] so that's what
i'm saying when you go on there on the
after page and sag they have checks that
belong to you
oh
that you don't get that you don't get
it's like for people who don't know this
let's pretend that you went to college
and they don't try to track you down or
if someone's no why would they do that
why would they want to [ __ ] do that
not only do you pay them unions help
their union yeah no no they don't do
that like i don't know if you know this
lee let's say you went to but you're
from boston right but let's say no let's
say during the summer you went to
college and then the summers you worked
at the movie theater and stuff like that
i guarantee
i guarantee that if you go to the state
of boston there are yeah you have three
checks in the state of both i do i have
what did i tell you i have a check from
uh a movie theater a restaurant in like
an old bank
it's crazy how much money are yours is
out there right now and this is for the
listeners
listening right now what you have no
idea i did not know this member my wife
is an accountant my wife has come into
the room a thousand times going by the
way
i found a check for you for a thousand
bucks what from warner brothers when you
shot analyzed that
they sent it to the hotel where you were
staying
no no no it's ridiculous wow you sit
there and go i've been with aphra since
1998.
and in 2004 they sent the hotel to the
marriott a check to the marriott hotel
in manhattan
how quickly do you uh you forget about
it you don't know yeah how quickly do
you get noticed if you're late on your
sag dues though bro they will shut you
down oh no they just won't let you shoot
anything they don't like [ __ ]
you call station 12. yeah and you find
out because as soon as you shoot
something like oh hey you got a call
from sag you're like oh [ __ ] no no no no
no no like by the time you're doing the
paperwork don't call you and go lisa i
had great news
you've booked the mcdonald's commercial
congratulations it's national regional
computer this that and also that's it
and all of a sudden about an hour later
i got a quarter to seven you get that
call lehigh we just got off the phone
with sag the production company
ah your station 12 what's that you can't
shoot you come up with 454 dollars
and you're like i don't have 454 dollars
and they don't give a [ __ ] now they do
they finance you i do have them i'll pay
that ahead of schedule yeah
like a hundred yeah they must have lost
their main the guy they wanted a few
times or they're like why don't we just
what's the deal yeah let's just pay it
just
that money yeah they won't do it the
production companies won't do it they're
crazy
i got my production company to pay for
sag for basketball really i never paid a
dollar for sag or after i got fired from
telemundo
what's your telemundo some cuban show in
1998 i got there at nine and i got fired
at lunchtime oh my god when i was at
lunchtime i'm sitting in my car and i
got the call i got the beep yeah i went
to a pay phone and my agent said by the
way they said
not to go back they'll pay you for the
day really yeah it was that quick and
you want me to tell you something it was
1998 and they paid for my after
and about three years ago i'm walking a
circle around that park
north hollywood park where where the
dinosaurs are by the way
dining by the sag
no no no right over here
north hollywood park
this is about three years ago i'm
walking with my wife right before my
wife had mercy me and her would walk
when she was pregnant and one day we
were walking the spanish guy from george
lopez's show the one on abc eight years
ago yeah ran up to me goes do you
remember me
and i go yeah yeah you're from the lopez
she goes no no he goes i did a show with
you on telemundo that you got fired from
he goes i never saw you after that but i
wanted to tell you i had nothing to do
with it
what
can i ask you something what happened he
goes
they didn't like the style of spanish
that you spoke
it was nothing personal
you're a cuban from new jersey and there
was a cuban from miami and the producers
or cubans from miami and he goes
i don't know exactly what you said
but i know that when you left for lunch
they were petrified
like they were
they were by the book cubans and the
words i had used
were kind of
uh savage cuban words that like a a
street slang
human would use oh really yeah this
member there's a couple different types
of cubans that have people there's
cubans that are very decent people
just say it like that
did that almost like
no they're very decent man
they weren't raised like i was and uh
years ago 99 2000
at the store i was doing the belly room
stories from a cuban street
and that day i went for an audition
and some kid came up to me we were
talking also one thing led to another
like are you from miami yeah
what's your name something alvarez oh
[ __ ] you're cuban yeah we shook hands
very nice you know i don't know he goes
what are you doing i'ma stand up
he goes do you have a show in town i go
tonight i got nine o'clock in the belly
room
and we went outside and talked about
cuban food and [ __ ]
dog they came to the belly room that
night him and his wife
on the way out they wouldn't even look
at me
i never saw that kid again he had my
number and everything
because he was like a decent [ __ ]
you know i was up there telling some
[ __ ] cuban [ __ ] gangster stories
these people don't need that aggravation
now did you just go to asian countries
oh [ __ ] what um
yeah no southeast asia i thought it was
in there just in that region no
australia no new zealand no i was
thinking of starting in sri lanka but i
didn't
start in myanmar and then i just went
sort of like east no have you ever been
there before no i went i had been to
thailand before
and so then i went to northern thailand
i was gonna go to laos
because i heard from some guy in myanmar
that this like cool like boat you can
take in laos
down like the river all the way it's
like a two-day slow boat
people trade [ __ ] booze
and have a good time i don't know make
friends and then you get to like some
city fintien
something like that bang bang
something like that
and then uh
yeah so i was headed there went to
northern thailand i got distracted there
went to more northern thailand for a
while
and then said [ __ ] it i'm not gonna go
to laos what was the best food
man vietnam was real good i like
cambodian food too
um thailand has really good food though
but you've had it before that's the
thing but some of that cambodian food
that look like man you gotta get some of
that that's all this chopped up beef
like real [ __ ] sauteed and [ __ ] over
rice did you have to get any shots to go
into any countries yeah like most of
them really yeah a bunch rabies shot
raby shot which is a rip because all it
gets you you got to take three of them
which by the way here they're 300 bucks
each if you go to another country uh
50 bucks
i got the first two here you have to
space them out and then i was going to
be there for the third one
50 bucks show them what it is yeah yeah
everything's cheaper there for drugs
everything's cheaper
oh my god and how many more shots did
you have to take just the three rabies
three rabies but the rabies only gets
you so after you get bit by some [ __ ]
wild dog you still gotta go get a bunch
of rabies shots it just buys you extra
days so that means like if you get the
rabies shots you have four days to go to
the hospital
and if you don't then you have a one day
to go to the hospital but you just
[ __ ] go to the hospital oh god
almighty there are no villages oh god or
if you are you just [ __ ] go and you
get to the hospital in a day you can get
anywhere in a day to a hospital and like
i've been by a [ __ ] bunch of and
they'll just start shooting you up
you're fine i'm just saying it's a
rip-off [ __ ] thing
so what you know
but i got some other [ __ ] too now when
you go
now when you go to immigration and tommy
you're going to miramar when do they
start giving you shots right they had
immigration no no
no i get it i went to a travel doctor
beforehand
um
and they give me the shots
they and then they look ahead of like
where are you gonna be and then you're
like yeah there's a malaria risk here
boom boom boom boom they found me like
that clinic in myanmar i told them where
i was gonna be
and then i emailed her i took her email
address that was one of the only ones
took it with me emailed her
um
said hey i'm in a new place so can you
find me another place that i can get
that shot and then she did so how many
shots all together to be [ __ ] james
bond and go around the world
[ __ ] you that's probably like probably
like five six five or six oh which one
hurt the most that one they get you on
the side of the arm you know what's that
one is that tetanus i don't know is that
is that malaria no they don't have
malaria i don't think i've had it
definitely
maybe
yeah
oh you should see how small those
condoms are out there
they got some little kids they're so
small
they're on like you're unusable they're
unusable
so why don't you just cut them in half
and glue them together why don't like
crazy glue them together then scotch
tape your dick and double join it with
[ __ ] uh
with uh you gotta be creative when
you're a freak dog i've been in those
positions late night where you got like
those little [ __ ] dick condoms yeah
you just get a scissor you hope she's
got crazy glue for her nails
in her purse you start gluing those
condoms together they're a little rough
but you just give her a little stabbing
you put the rough in on the insides yeah
because you're a gentleman yeah
i'm saying so what you do is you get the
scratches yeah listen to what you do i'm
not [ __ ] with you oh no i don't take
your glue
and you fold this together so nobody
gets their feelings hurt you put the
glue right down pop and then around your
dick you put a little duct tape
so it's loose ends yeah see that see
that that freak like when i was
when i was 21 22
23 and he used condoms i was even scared
then like i didn't really believe in
condoms like after 85 everybody had the
condom scare i didn't really believe in
congress what do you mean
duct tape your dick shut up
duct tape your dick shot at four in the
morning when you're coked up and you're
getting dead dick the only way to keep
that condom on is to duct tape it onto
your dick
and even if it shrinks up you're still
giving her a stab and it's in there
flapping but what are you gonna do
you know i thought i used to be a
[ __ ] freak of freaks disgusting
so you got to cover yourself but i never
believe duct tape
at the tip at the end over here by the
shaft
because i don't like the the feeling of
her liquid on my little circle for some
reason oh it always creeps me out
what's your circle in the top circle
like let's say you have a woman on top
here right yeah and
all right so you have a condom on that's
great but what about that area around
your nutsack that juice from her monkey
yeah goes down to your nut sacking
around and after you have sex it just
feels like you sweat but you didn't yeah
and sometimes it is sweat but it's like
[ __ ] it's a mixture yeah and it's like
get off the mat always gives me the
creeps like you gotta have that foot
fungus stuff around and go on a hot
shower i don't know why so that's why
like
the only time
the only time i had sex with a
prostitute was
until i was in high school when i went
to the 10 40 club and what did this most
disgusting thing
that i could remember about it was her
bouncing up and down
and i kept going i could hear like
like
but i could also feel like whatever was
coming out of there coming down to you
rubbing around my helmet like developing
and i kept thinking about her dirty ass
you were wearing a condom no you have to
work on them she puts it on for you and
everything
i i was just disgusted and that's what i
was discussed about like i don't want
just a condom so then how do you make
not get that you duct tape from where to
where down to like your mid thigh like
you're not saying you're on your nutsack
your protection
like i want to invent something that's
like a condom but something also to
protect your nuts all the way to your
thigh yeah something leather on the end
of it something like those you know
those glasses that have the connectors
to the side yeah the leather the little
things something completely different
where you could scotch tape it it's got
tapes to the inside by yourself oh you
don't want to you don't surround your
balls i don't want no fluid on none of
my body but that's the best of your body
if you know her if you know her yeah if
you grew up with it and she banged some
of your friends i get it
but if you're just meeting a girl at a
bar on tinder no fluids you would have
no fluids
oh you don't know where she's been and
she don't know where you've been yeah
but isn't it the most like balls are the
most important part like those are not
the most not the first blog okay i'm
gonna say that i'm gonna swallow i wash
before i go in the shower i'll wash i
would never show up to somebody's house
and go hello with 10 hour disgusting
body parts yeah and i'm a fat dude
that's people hooked up in new york
no no no you have to take it anybody who
i hooked up with even early on i would
always coax them into the shower
you got to take a shower in my house
before i eat that ass for me to feel
comfortable and relaxed
unless you just went from your house and
you showered when i pick you up like if
i picked you up and i smelt the shampoo
in your hair and then we went to eat and
then we went back to my house and i hate
your monkey we're all right yeah but if
i'm picking you up from a full day of
work no you got to get in the shower
i would coach you into the shower let's
do a line of blow and put some in your
[ __ ] and eat in the shower i want you
to pee on me gotta tell them some story
to get you in the shower
right or wrong i don't [ __ ] know no
that makes sense i guess especially when
you go across you gotta go up steps you
gotta go like that i couldn't imagine
going to
i love asian women but i can't imagine
going all the way around the world of
china yeah and sleeping with a woman
without like full protection oh yeah
yeah no but that means just condo
because no no full protection i want
full protection what there's no full
protection there's no such thing as a
rash guard yeah like a rash guard or
something
i need something i can't sleep at night
that creeps me out so you want something
like maybe a wetsuit with a dick hole in
it
and then you could cover that up the
bottom to be like a bikini yeah with a
with a condom yeah like a bikini yeah
something you put your dick in maybe
it's something to throw it away the
whisk away yeah yeah the whole thing
like i'm too yeah i guess
really
i can't you want me the only way to
describe my skin yeah [ __ ]
since i'm a [ __ ] kid i have [ __ ]
skin
my skin is weak how i haven't died is
beyond me because when i was a kid let
me tell you something i went to florida
one time and i was forced to wear i was
from uh from the time i was a baby
i had a phone
when you went to my house today you
looked at my spirit altar
now you can't tell you have to go to the
living room yeah i saw you listen
there's a picture of me in the living
room yeah if you walk up to it you go
joey what happened to your hair
oh because when it was like the [ __ ]
elvis impersonator here i was three
first off when i was three my hair was
red
really
red completely different guys you would
die you guys would bocco
what the [ __ ] happened like an irish kid
like it was crazy really i remember my
mom had a locker hand i used to go whose
hair is this
and she goes that's your hair when did
it change
like when i was about six did you get us
did you get a fright
a what a fright
turns your hair you know maybe um i got
hit in the head with that flashlight
when i was six and got stitches really
maybe the bloats who knows what's gonna
happen no no who knows what could have
happened
but uh i had like i went to florida one
time
and had to get rushed to the hospital in
florida because the skin on my arms
uh the sun
burnt like first what's the worst skin
burn you could have third degree first
degree so it was like the no no the
lightest one like guys it was blistered
and i had patches like i got burned with
acid on my arms really like i had you
already
until i was about 10. if you saw me i
haven't i had scars on both arms over
here from the hole that the sun
had burnt in my arms in miami
when i was about eight i went to karate
and one day my mother goes you have to
take a shower karate and i'll pick you
up from there
i got a fungus on my feet when i was
eight i had to get taken to the hospital
because it was [ __ ] oh so by the time i
was like 10 i wasn't allowed to take
showers in nobody's house
really couldn't go to swimming pools why
because this can be fun because my feet
my feet would get i was the type of guy
that would get a rash
yeah no no it's not my part no no it
wasn't my my skin
was just [ __ ] weak rashes
[ __ ] uh itches ringworm when i was
12. no way yeah man i was one of those
[ __ ] kids even though i bathed i had
to put a special cream on every day and
then once i started doing drugs my skin
tightened up
and here we go
something happened no i got it
why do you think i got the fungi toe why
do you think my feet look like they've
been run over by a [ __ ] truck
because my skin i can't really take
showers in places i gotta have the
flip-flops on and even then
even then you don't want to do it no
even then i get something on my feet
like when i go to jiu jitsu i have to
bring
those things you know the soap
i get the towelettes i get the whole
package if you went down on a girl would
you do it like through like a i guess
like a
shower curtain kind of thing no you know
i love you and i can't lie to you yeah
when i eat [ __ ] yeah
i gotta eat an acapella i don't even
want you to have a shield or not i want
all the minerals okay if it's got
something in it i want a blister on my
lip because i'm saying
if you don't get a blister on your lip
you ain't [ __ ] anyway
that [ __ ] ain't worth eating if you
don't get like a blister under your
tongue
you'll get a little blissed under your
tongue from eating that monkey for like
an hour no i guess i haven't been doing
it right that's the problem that's why i
eat another star it's time for a star
what's this nothing's happening put the
siren put the siren on lee shotari it's
time for the siren
what's the siren
it's that time where's tony bennett
sucker
that's hilarious
what's the story you need that star
you're going to stare on no
what is the story
look he tried to pull a dummy on me yeah
not a lot of getting your throat you
might as well let it be doubling a
dissolve
you have to chew it yet but there you go
there you go
it's just a regular sunday night here on
the church ladies and gentlemen look at
him look at him he's about to spit up
who leave you is it too much sugar
no no it's seven calories of peace
[Music]
let me give some shout outs to 100
calorie bags
tomas lynn
spagy
james kennedy brad ebert
meg my little asian princess locomotive
j mac
off the cases 1971 capital and my main
man
derek nielsen do not forget i'll be at
the ice house thursday night working out
with uncle joey 10 bucks you're in at 8
30 out of there by 10 and we all have a
couple [ __ ] yuck yucks and you start
the week off on a good uh
tip top toe magoo and the following week
friday and saturdays four shows levy
town
oh [ __ ] governors
there you have it [ __ ]
let me give you the other side of the
coin now yeah
i tell you what man
first of all wait wait wait of what coin
oh you're okay i know what you're
talking about the other side okay first
of all yeah
i missed you yeah i'm sorry about that i
missed you i wrote you a letter you know
no no it's funny because
i told you write me a letter right away
but while you were gone i said that's
very selfish of me because
i know what he's going through
you know uh
taking time away from your life is the
same it's like me putting you in prison
in camden new jersey
you didn't do anything you were just
free but you got away from this circle
yeah
you disconnected yourself which is
[ __ ] tougher than death you know i
know later on they found the hidden
secret email i mean
uh
and all that [ __ ] which i could care
less i didn't want to bother you by no
means
by no means i was concerned about your
parents if something would happen you'd
be gone how bad you felt but they had a
way to get ahold of you you sent them
flowers one night one day you were
checking in with them i know you have
your own little way to check but i know
you wanted to clear your head
so i could care less i said a prayer for
you i lick candles for you you're out
there
i thought you were getting your dick
sucked did you want to go out there did
you want to do something like that me
yeah when you heard that i was gone were
you like yeah i would like to go
somewhere
no i was worried about you and i was i
felt like de niro and the dear hunter
eventually if something bad happened i'd
have to go over there and get you you
know they want you to end up it was
weird about a week after you left yeah
i'm watching tv one night and it's dion
it's about his
uh what's his name he goes to vietnam
and he kind of loses it and while he's
there he starts playing uh russian
roulette oh yeah and he [ __ ] gets
good at it he's like one of the best in
vietnam or whatever the [ __ ] he is and
de niro comes to get him one day you
never saw it no i never saw deer huh i
gotta do that huh
de niro dear hunter scene for my man
your fear
listen to me i was so high on stars
like it was uh
it was right before you know i gave up
stars for lent
did you know that no i gave up stars how
long is that 40 days yeah 40 days four
days yeah i was like
maybe a couple days before that
but what i did was i also like it i went
home one night and i thought about you
because i was watching this movie and in
my head i'm like
i'm gonna have to get a passport and go
over there and get him he's going to end
up like
[ __ ] this christopher walken it was
so safe man no i know you were safe
but the funny thing i know i know that's
what everybody said like what's what if
something happens to you but i'm like
what do you mean you know like joe asked
about you
i spoke to duncan about you you know
tripoli asked
yeah tebow asked
you know it was weird
i felt that the other people asking
i mean i know uh what's his name loves
you and all that
good show this [ __ ] let me see
that you i i can't believe you've never
seen this [ __ ] this is what i was
worried about ari is this one with the
nurses behind them and she's not no
watch this [ __ ] this is you
and this is uncle joe he's going to get
you oh he's another big actor
oh
that looks tremendous they've done some
great work
[Laughter]
oh
who's the other guy he's just some new
guy no that's what gets christopher
walken that's you
is he new not sorry is he new to the
thing no he's going to get him in
vietnam de niro watch
you imagine a shinari oh my gosh oh
god damn it it's going to be all right
nikki go ahead shoot
look at this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] they run you're
going to die ari this is it this is real
[Applause]
oh you're gonna die you [ __ ]
you're gonna die
oh come on
go ahead nikki god just
[Music]
these two guys grew up together oh my
god they both went to vietnam together
and he stayed de niro goes home and goes
back together
this is brilliant
is one of the greatest movies to come
out of the 70s
this is one of the greatest movies oh my
god
this is when they had an original idea
look at this [ __ ] oh they keep slapping
they're not [ __ ] around here
[Laughter]
what
come on
come on how do you get so many bullets
in there
wait there's one this is my movies with
movies though
this is from movies and movies kid this
is real this is another one you need
four [ __ ] hours of your time yeah
yeah
this is uh you get so many bullets in
there what do you mean the one he was
gonna shoot himself with he had like
four shots of there no he knew i think
he knew that he had one bullet he knew
so he shot one guy he went shot and
created havoc and went for it [ __ ]
tremendous movement was on that night
and i was thinking about you what night
oh i'm like this [ __ ] aria over there
playing
russian
those blue yeah like it you know they
showed you no no but like in those areas
you know they just don't do it anymore
did you see the girl sucky sucky any of
those girls still at last time i i steer
clear of bangkok it's gross
it's the worst city
it's just filthy there's little kids
working like 2 a.m
bangkok is disgusting it's good for like
one or two days to see it and then just
never go back
all the [ __ ] sex
tourism is like so in your face
that's where they had these
chicks last night that's where they have
kids and everything yeah they go you can
buy kids yeah absolutely
it's just too much and they're all dirty
the children
and there's loose dogs about
if you would have stayed where else
would you have gone oh okay well for
sure the philippines for sure yeah i
mean it was right there i ran out of
time i would have i would have for sure
gone that's probably next have you been
there before no
didn't you go there kickboxing or
something what that's thailand
i went to watch kickboxing in thailand
uh thai kick thai boxing digit yeah it
was pretty cool they played this weird
instrument yeah yeah right
not this time
no the time before i did though they
would walk through i guess this one was
too nice of place
no you know i did gamble on
[ __ ] fighting
where
timor leste
is that he's timor it's [ __ ] in
indonesia if you keep going around
indonesia it's like one of those islands
is split in half like new guinea and
look like you know right in the middle
and to this west team where it's part of
indonesia and then timor leste which
means east two more i guess cocaine
heroin now come up to you no uh
some people have no ice
nothing nobody came up to you with
nothing exotic the whole time america
come here we have sucky sucky pill
nothing no
no not once really crazy that's crazy
that is crazy not once i mean i got some
stuff but nothing like crazy
yeah
everybody's on a [ __ ] budget in
hostels they don't have much like which
is good time for like drugs you said in
your letter that the hostels
uh did something to you like staying at
the hostels yeah
it was just so nice you just make
friends with people
you just like lose your line of what
you're like accept and not accept it
just go down so fast you realize like
who kids the [ __ ] it's a bed
it's fine it's fine
just let me [ __ ] sleep it's fine i
have earplugs it's okay just let me put
my head down people snoring fart that
happens sometimes this german guy [ __ ]
up on i wasn't i hadn't [ __ ] for like
a month over a month and some german guy
just [ __ ] given it to a chick in the
bunk bed above me and went over so i
could like look at the [ __ ] bed
moving
the mattress and an occasional knee
oh i'm so [ __ ] horny god it was the
worst but generally it's not that
generally everyone's just polite
and i had some [ __ ] chinese they're
the worst at any point when you're in
the [ __ ] hostel you're like i don't
need this [ __ ] i could stay at the four
seasons i know i could i know i could
but then i know i'd just be
shortchanging myself but i would do it
when i was like uh so if i'm in a city
for a few days it's like i got to meet
people this is where you [ __ ] meet
people yeah but if i go through for one
day let's say i take a long bus to get
to like an airport city and i get in at
like 7 p.m 8 p.m or whatever you know
and then my my flight leaves the next
day like 10 or 11
then it's like i'm not gonna meet
anybody or do anything i'm just gonna go
to sleep
so it's like [ __ ] it give me a hotel and
a hot shower
you know
and then i [ __ ] go to the airport and
make my friends the next place
what's your next trip going to be where
do you want to go i have an idea i don't
want to get into it yet but i have an
idea i got to learn a couple languages
too i want to learn some languages i
learned a little tattoo
in that last country i went to
before i went it made it easier
now can you do me a favor and drop a
package off in cuba
people are going to cuba now you might
as well go can you go no you could go
and do a show i could book a show for
you at my cousin's bar wait but you you
would want to go
at this point i do and see my sister and
give her a hug yeah man
this passport thing is getting out of
control this attorney you can't get it
right
it's open now he said that the thing is
[ __ ] so buried
that the clerk said that
she doesn't think the judge will look at
it what just that because you have no
passport no no no this is a yeah because
i have no passport but this isn't i'm
trying to get this
squashed
and it's just bureaucracy it just takes
time and every time i gotta send a
thousand bucks paypal
so it's it's uh
you can't get it
if you have hopefully sign it off
i'll go right to worship boulevard i'll
i'll pay the 279 for a rush job and if
you don't believe me i will take jet
blue like a [ __ ] straight to the
right cuba i'll walk in my factory to my
cousin's [ __ ] bar
i'll drink on the arm and i will call
justin from the factory and go
get such and such on the phone yeah i'm
shooting a special here in 90 days yeah
make it happen
yeah for sure you should spanish in cuba
no no i would shoot in english on a
saturday night when the americans are
down there for the weekend yeah and
guess what i'll give a date where all
church people can go down the [ __ ]
nevada you're gonna go yeah yeah yeah
you might as well go down now
let's do it now
by the way
before i say anything else listen man
like i told you guys for years that
i don't know i'm not like regular people
i hate the word fans this is a family we
talk [ __ ] we learn from one another's
you guys email me
the connection is made at the shows
we lost somebody really [ __ ] cool
really cool mr la lingas out of chicago
you know my thoughts and the prayers of
all the church people please
send them to bob lolingis
his dad passed uh today and uh i love
him to death
he's more than just a friend he's like
family
he came to the special and everything
great family i just want to extend my
love to your family mr williams
rest in peace
sorry about that but he's a good dude so
i just wanted to well how'd he go
huh how'd he go
um
just some lung issues he was older yeah
so you're lucky you still got your
family your parents your brothers yeah
where's your crazy brother did you bump
into him like in [ __ ] saigon or
something no i was thinking of it i took
his email address i never emailed him i
took his email address and said if i got
done early maybe i'll go through there
go skiing with him
and swiss alps
he looked right out there
but no i didn't get done early so
so i didn't see him you know i know
you're examining them next month i know
you're a long time and i remember when
you were the king of commercials yeah i
remember you and i talked to lawrence
the other day no you told me i remember
you and i having
intense conversations at four in the
morning about
people booking us and
who will help us theatrically and you
had a stiff for a while
ralphie's x guy and that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i had a [ __ ] it's just so weird how
you know you wanted all these things and
you started uh
this is not happening in a [ __ ] room
that didn't even serve booze i told the
pink floyd story and mark maron and
steve agee you know and
all these things went in your direction
you went to montreal you taped a special
and also one day you wake up and you're
like you know what man this is a lot
more than what i bargained for i just
wanted to crack jokes and be left alone
like yeah i wanted so many things for
years yeah and we were the type i don't
want that fame i see some of those guys
like
oh no no no no no listen i don't even
i i told that story about the box on
your special on your this is not how you
know and it's so weird
i mean that's nice that's a nice little
you know side effect of it
no i really do believe that that
i drive a subaru man yeah i'm a certain
type of dude
and that's the type of person i am and
you know what man
the thing that scares me is that you and
i have seen people who came here from
the beginning and were zeros yeah
and all of a sudden they got a little
money all of a sudden everything changed
about that you know i don't know if they
lost their drive what they lost yeah
they lost their drivers me i like my ear
in the [ __ ] dungeon i like my
spirit from time to time
you gotta go to the comedy store from
time to
you gotta go to different comedy clubs
and you know you gotta if you're a real
comedian if you were just a flash of a
pam with somebody who did comedy as a
means to an end yeah so you got a tv
show
bam we get it no worries but don't
[ __ ] go out on the weekends and take
people's money and waste their time
at least you know at least we're out
there banging it out and uh i'm doing
three a night a few nights out here yeah
but people have no idea how much
effort goes into this and listen you
know i remember 90 in 2000 [ __ ] 98
joe rogan took me to the riviera
to do the
show friday and saturday i got 200 for
the weekend for two shows
horrible and they gave me the cafeteria
the [ __ ] menu in the dungeon the
dungeon down the riviera dungeon oh my
god hurry up and wait and uh
if you have to wait till after 10 to eat
you can eat with the regular people oh
was
closed the shows were great they were
packed rogan sold them out yeah but the
highlight of the weekend was the guitar
player from guns n roses
slash how i saw him on the on the
southwest flight with us
and i didn't say nothing i saw him at
the airport i didn't say nothing
and then bam there he was at the hotel
doing a signing and i didn't say nothing
and i went up to my room and i had no
reefer rogan didn't smoke then yeah they
called jonah you had a reefer
i was like on my own i couldn't sleep
and they pumped oxygen in the rooms they
said that's why i couldn't sleep so i
went for a walk and he was at the bar by
himself with slash
and i started talking to a man and i go
hey man
you know i don't want to bother you but
i'm a fan of yours it's great and we
started talking about comedy because i
had met him and i met our meds room
years earlier he was there one night
watching comedy and he came by
and said you guys were all funny you
know who gives a [ __ ] it was we were
like
doing comedy a couple years so i just
reminded him there was nobody around him
it wasn't like he had a chick with him
it was a perfect time and we got into a
conversation about axel yeah and he goes
when are you the happiest he goes right
now he goes you're broke i go [ __ ] yeah
that's what he said to you yeah he goes
are you broke right now what part of
your economy career and i'm going broke
we both said laugh and he goes
but i guarantee you someday when you do
start making money you'll think back to
this time and think about how good of a
time you have it yeah because once you
start involving attorneys it becomes a
business a lot of people can't handle
that business yeah i mean he told me a
[ __ ] pretty good little speech he
talked about actually he goes that's why
when you do work for free
later on when you get paid you think
about all that work you did for free and
it makes your life a lot easier yeah
it doesn't feel like you can live on
nothing you've already lived in nothing
you've already lived on nothing so it
doesn't feel like you're getting
something for free and i'm saying you
want to become religious
or whatever the [ __ ] you want to become
that should be part of the training of
becoming like an independent artist
it's not that i live broke for like yeah
some people read an article and they
really believe it some people read their
social media and they believe you know
yeah yeah some people want to believe
what they want to believe so
you're never going to change that you
know it's just uh
what the [ __ ] it is i'm just happy
that you went
you came back
and here we are you got your netflix
special
coming out july 20th july 18th 18th
sorry about yeah july 18th
18th
and i will remind them july 18th yeah
you are in new york now this is a double
special twin special yeah what's the
first one first one's called childhood
okay children excuse me the person is
called children you hate you for kids
mostly picture for kids okay mercy aside
and what's the second one uh no no no
let me tell you something yeah that day
with mercy i could see your hatred for
kids when you put it through the
basketball net which was hysterical you
just turned her over and put her to the
hoop she didn't know what to expect but
she loved it she loved you to death i
could tell this [ __ ] i don't
like kids i've seen a bunch of people do
things to kids never have i seen a guy
slam dunk a child i like when she's
jumping on the sofa and i just rip her
legs out from under her oh yeah
she just slams her head
cushion
and she keeps waiting like at the
surfboard and then he just waits for the
moment
swipe down if you know that she loves
you
she loved it she was picking your leg
and grabbing yeah
she's a savage no no that's in her blood
that's over i noticed that a long time
ago
she likes being tackled and all that
[ __ ] so i'm happy
yeah and what's the second the other
half's adulthood and that's like [ __ ]
stuff you get into when you're not like
a [ __ ] a dad and a husband
you know it's the other way
how old do you know 43.
no plans i'm getting mad
no plans on children that's it you're a
free bird i don't think so i don't want
it i don't want it at all i don't blame
you
listen nobody wants funny but god has a
different plan yeah exactly you're
following me that's trouble that's why
it's trouble nobody wants it nobody
about you i love these they always start
thinking about it as soon as they get
pregnant they just consider me and
they're gonna both get jobs and we're
gonna
make a little fortune after three years
we're going to start trying to have a
child [ __ ] you might have three
cocktails at that pizza place around the
corner
lee stix it in your culo and there you
go
you don't know when you're gonna have a
[ __ ] kid you really don't you really
really don't really know if you don't
want a [ __ ] kid you gotta wear a
condom and a condom after that and you
gotta dump them after three weeks
because they're gonna start asking
creepy questions you know what i'm
saying like when are we gonna start
dating full-time because dating
full-time means one saturday we hold
hands and we both go down to the
sanitarium and get blood tests to see if
we have the hiv
and if we both are clean we look at each
other and go great we go condomless you
know and now you start
start all over again yeah now you start
[ __ ] you get that kid problem and you
have that kid problem that she's on the
pill but you know what the pill when
it's always you for some reason it works
99 of the time guess who's the one
percent
me
everybody yeah everybody in america
gets knocked somebody up one time i did
get somebody pregnant she told me later
she told me later that was she wasn't
asking for anything she goes like three
years ago i got pregnant because the
pill didn't work i had to get an
abortion it was way after the fact i
didn't know what to say
you didn't give her flowers no i was
like do you want money
for the
and she was like no
that's so good and i was like what do
you
that's so [ __ ] embarrassing i gave
her a high five
no you didn't yeah i was like i don't
know good job i mean right
what if she i didn't trust her i didn't
even know about it for three years
god i mean yeah she she was way harder
for her
but i mean like good choice
for sure the right choice you want to
bug it
hell yes man all right it's that time
you want the big meal no the big mule
not this little one the little one kicks
too hard it's like little chili peppers
yeah let's do a [ __ ] meal shot here
we are you ready for the meal
not really but sure why not you gotta do
it now we gotta get [ __ ] together
nine o'clock nine o'clock oh we're good
we're good
yeah no i don't want to get anybody
pregnant lee you want kids
i used to think like definitely for sure
i did yeah
that's what we're talking about ladies
and gentlemen
now i'm not so sure
really why not
jesus honestly just how expensive they
are do you think your kid would come out
high
like you would have it in his
bloodstream so much
possible it's definitely it's definitely
a worry it's possible but uh no i mean
and lee i'm so sorry we're gonna have to
cut your your boy's eyelids open they
seem to be closed but oh no no no he's
just squishing even before i moved out
here people always thought i was high
like small eyelids i guess
yeah i'm sure it was before or not now
yeah now that they know you they know
you're [ __ ] huh
we'll do a little one of these how about
that irish oh yeah okay here you go
killer i'll light a fee
it's the
moment on the church what's happening
now
please on deck
wait you should be over there like
stretching and [ __ ] your hands are set
tonight i should be over here
jumping over the table
oh that's the mule that's right there oh
my god
oh my
god that is [ __ ] killer
you took it to the next level
oh my god ari that was a tremendous
bunker
lee you're gonna have to beat that one i
don't think i don't want to no you got
no choice
you guys are jews and arms
that was tremendous
[Laughter]
your heart stops you [ __ ] look i'm
telling you this weed
makes you lose consciousness for like a
minute
which is the worst ari this weed or the
drinking your own pee
this weed is worse than a throat no
lisa are you ready to go
i guess so
you going between us too
what you go before me and after me and
before him he doesn't join the podcast
you know what i'm gonna give you a
little earthquake no thank you
earthquake earthquake
the earthquake wind is good why is it
called earthquake because the comic gave
it to you we're saving it no no we're
not oh earthquakes we're not saving it
we've never saved it joey what was the
best weeds you've ever had the third eye
for sure third eye was tremendous what
was the other one that was real good
back then
there was so many of them i mean
we're living right here yeah
this [ __ ] that i get that i don't even
know what it is
and it sits in the back room yeah and
then one morning i wake up and i look at
it and i go let me try it
can i open it forget what it is and it's
nice and dry and i smoke it i don't know
who gave it to me i don't know why they
gave it to me i don't know how to get a
hold of this person now
but that's what happens to me all the
[ __ ] time
i get such great [ __ ] reefer
and i let it sit for so long
that it's immense you know what i'm
saying
yeah
there you go give this to your buddy and
here's a little leah i'm so happy for
you lee's going to town tonight lee's
not [ __ ] around
with a frown
never down
lisa are you ready to split a sugar cube
no i'm not spelling it
why can't i even get a full sugar cube
what if you want a full shoe okay
yeah we got one might as well let's do
it no no no no we're not doing it i'm
saying if i'm gonna do no let's do it
[ __ ] it it's sunday night my
my my [ __ ] day is wide open let's do
it it's sunday night live my life
what do you do you ain't going to stay
at home and play video games i don't
play video games give them the light
well y'all reach your feet let's do this
shitley and keep it over him because if
not he'll cheat he
breathe it in you just take it as a big
shot you get a chance at it still no no
keep stay with him stay with him stay
with him stay with him stay with him
stay with him stay with me okay pull it
pull it
get there now get there you're almost
there get there son get there
there you go he's a let out you've
earned it nah that wasn't a good one
look that's a half a fact
that was not very much enough he always
does that you breathe
he has to do another one now give me
this you're burning it too slow i've
been telling him he's got a super saiyan
you don't believe me give me that let's
give them i don't have any long power
look how much green there is i know okay
you don't need yourself no no no no
you're not eating your salad
come here give me that so much green
left yeah he's he wants to [ __ ] around
because it's you over there i'm not
[ __ ] what are you doing walking
around [ __ ] around
this you've done this to yourself yeah
you [ __ ] up you just gotta [ __ ]
okay so you want like a really huge
breathe all that hard fine clear that
thing
oh my jesus here comes the torch of
death here
oh my gosh
stay right there don't go nowhere stay
right there don't go nowhere
stay right there don't go away go ahead
freeze out of your nose breathe out of
your nose breathe out of your nose keep
sucking keep sucking let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
listen now go go go for broke
go [ __ ] sucker
get there get there almost almost
you're not close you're not close you're
not close let it go let it go
you're not close
so much left
the other one i thought you could make
this one at some point there's no way
you're going to make it why do you have
to
i thought
you think you're playing you play with
people you don't think i know
you do these little see look at that
finish that you got to be an animal you
got to finish that right there i can't
open my left eye right now that's okay i
left that little hurry up you got to get
that smoke before that does hurry up
liam just pick up the valve that's it
hurry up no don't do that to it because
it stagnates
yeah you're involved you can hold that
way go ahead go go ahead pimp just just
hit it just hit it
there you go almost there don't throw up
oh my god don't throw up
he coughed like he was gonna throw up
oh you still have something left i'll
just be honest though he's still
swirling a bit he's super sad he's
swirling a bit he's all right that's
cool but he's in the super set there he
goes he's fine oh my gosh are you gonna
throw up not yet oh you look like you're
about to have you thought up on this
podcast before yes oh my gosh one time
but no we thought oh my god
right after chocolate mushroom position
no way
i'm doing del rey and rainbow
yeah we've got wow he didn't know what
he was he kept thinking he kept saying
he didn't want to go to the hospital
his eye was stuck
but you know what he's tougher than most
[ __ ]
what's his name right out of here the
noho park and walked around and hit him
oh and benjamin
he hit him in trees like
he saw the light of day listen what's
the man left here had to go to the
hospital
we've had some [ __ ] casualties here
but listen it's all in good fun who left
you had to go to the hospital hater
aydah left here went home she had to go
to the hospital my drinks yeah and in
the morning she told the doctor because
man i've never done that before laughing
goes sure you haven't
he walked out of the room
you know it was funny with her
she was the best because she had done
like a half a bong hit
and we were having a great conversation
yeah me and him are eating stars [ __ ]
around like you know i taunt them the
whole night went back and forth and
finally she looked me straight in the
face and said can i have one and i go
yeah she reached out took it ate it
and then [ __ ] and then
we kept talking here for a couple
minutes
and next thing you know hurry i could
see her switching gears no way like i
saw it
like dawg listen i like [ __ ] around
like i haven't given a guy i like having
a good time
there's some people who can handle
certain things
because they've done them before like i
don't
i don't get mad kamikaze you've been
there before and i don't get mad
kamikaze lee but you can't kamikaze like
somebody who doesn't get it what does
kamikaze mean like give somebody 1200
milligrams when they don't get hot yeah
if somebody gets hurt and you do acid
and you do mushrooms and yeah
you know what who gives a [ __ ] give them
300. rock this world nothing's going to
happen to you no what's her name said
cat what's her name kate condit
coily cat quickly no
condit what's up
saying that
she goes you gave a star to somebody one
night and somebody gave it to me
and she goes i had two beers and i ate
the star
and she goes i was walking down the
hallway at the comedy store
and she goes i never felt so enough
nothing like that in my life before joey
oh i hadn't heard through the grapevine
people had called me up and said hey man
did you give kim condom a starless and i
go no
i saw her at the store and they go man
she was [ __ ] up on one of your stars
so i bumped into her the other night and
she told me the [ __ ] story or what
happened to it i felt terrible
what'd you do that night
you know that doesn't just sit in the
front bar and just like put her head
down i wasn't there i left i went home
and the next day i heard stories and
then redman said yes she ate one of your
stars
she was squinting when she talked to
people she could only see out of one eye
i don't mind kamikaze [ __ ] but
not somebody who doesn't get high that's
not yeah yeah that's not right yeah well
you didn't try to but yeah
so if you disappear again you're going
to disconnect all [ __ ] avenues again
yeah disconnect that's the way to do it
disconnect that's the way to do it
sometimes people
you know man sometimes life uh moves a
little faster than what you wanted and
nobody nobody ever has the balls most
people go
how can i take a break
i've worked my whole life together
they're like what if you missed
something what are you gonna miss what
are you gonna miss just say i'll do it
later or then i'm not here don't get
someone else crazy
the strength you had because i know i
can never do it
like especially now with a child yeah
you know eight years ago when it was
just me and terry right now at this
point in my life january how i felt yeah
i could see myself going to cuba
and renting a house for six months
learning how to speak spanish all over
again
and going to where they buried my father
and going to where they buried my
grandmother and my grandfather and
taking lean on for a few weeks
and putting it on tape and
going to my uh
cousin's bar on the weekend and just do
comedy there friday and saturday and
host the open mic if they have one or
whatever you know just [ __ ]
like i said on the weekends there's so
many tourists from all over that go down
there
that you could do i know that on fridays
and saturdays for sure
my cousin has a dj down there every
friday
somebody popular
like bismarck or something they go down
there on fridays and saturdays what's
his name was in there
you know the man with uh the check
what's the beyonce
jay-z jay-z yeah they all go down there
oh and what really i like [ __ ] with
people
i like [ __ ] with people so
nobody started really asking questions
about it till the end of january oh
really oh yeah by the end of january for
like three days i was like
uh you know
damn he didn't write me a letter and
then i just said to myself you know what
man he had so much on his mind
god knows what the [ __ ] he's doing i
just hope god's watching him or whatever
and my wife said you got some crazy
leather there and i looked like it was
you
and i didn't read it right away really
no i put it in my office and i read it
that night oh nice when i was more
relaxed and i smiled and the next day i
called justin
and i told him and then i told him i
called derek and i told them the
instructions you had on there
oh yeah and
it was funny for days after that i kept
getting calls from them
you know like they were really uh they
wanted to know but
i don't know if it was concerned it was
just really weird you know
then i didn't hear nothing for a while
and then one day i went to the store and
they pulled me aside and they go harry
was spotted on facebook
it was like you had become the guy from
boston what's his name
why did he bulge it like he became
whitey bulger
you know my phone lit up the next day
everybody was hitting me
he came up on facebook he looks well
what the [ __ ] do you know he looks well
you know what i'm saying
you mean like not in a torture chamber
yeah yeah like he looks well because
chains are on my wrist i could find it i
didn't even bother looking for it
i got tagged by somebody hiking or
something and then about another two
weeks later there was a signing again
you were like hannibal like that
there was a sighting in vienna or some
[ __ ]
you know oh they were [ __ ] then you
sent somebody else a letter and now that
really drove them crazy and in the
letter
you mentioned you didn't know if you
were going to come home
for the summer festival oh my god
all of a sudden three of my phones rang
at the same time
managers agents producers
do you know if ari's coming back for the
festival in nashville
hilarious you had him on the ropes for a
couple weeks
so they were [ __ ] petrified so i
would get smoke signals on a daily have
you heard from hari is he going to go to
nashville and i'd say listen
if he doesn't go are you guys in shock i
was begging for you
if you would have called me
and said what do you think i would have
said don't come take the under stay
another month
don't come back because i was [ __ ]
with them over here
you had them in shock
so what happened was you pick up
you abandon ship and all of a sudden
gabriel iglesias like the number four
guy at ca comes in and goes i'm quitting
so now they're all concerned everybody's
quitting right
i'm surprised you didn't start like
negotiating on ari's behalf for like
this for like the gig for playing
10 more i could have [ __ ] i could
have gabriel was like [ __ ] that yeah let
me get out of here if this was 10 years
ago
let them all fall if this was 12 years
ago
i could
put together a plan where they would
have given me money and i could have
wired it yeah that's really good like
listen army needs 10 000 to come back
you could swindle oh
oh no you know yeah he's been he didn't
show no no no no would i already see any
of it
oh sure i could start tormenting them
i would start tormenting them at the
beginning of february about the festival
in nashville and i would start like
hitting them up every day i got an email
for murray
what did it say it said that he's doing
the festival
okay good we'll start booking it and
then i would call him the next day and
go listen i got an email from mario he
doesn't look good
he's gonna go to bangkok and he wants to
join wrestling school
so he's not going to make it to
nashville i would just do that for a
month
till like march camp and i go listen
hari can't tap into his bank account he
doesn't want nobody to know where he's
at
but send me 2 500.
i could have got them every two weeks
for 2500 that's how desperate are you
coming back
he could have got him for a little piece
oh yeah oh yeah little pieces oh they
tracked down the first money okay they
can get it through and they had to go
through another hoop
just a little bit more
yeah no no you could say whatever the
[ __ ] you wanted
it was crazy that's how crazy you were
driving
they were waking up every morning
no if you would have hit me up on an
email and said what do you think i would
have said stay there another month but
send them an email every day and tell
them you're coming
right like [ __ ] with them
and the day of before the festival up
and go my plane got shot down in
bangalore
see you guys next monday yeah just make
up a name they would have never known
for sure i'll be back from montreal just
because they were so cracked about the
gabriel thing
everybody in general was cracked about
the gabriel thing and now you're over
there being kung fu providing [ __ ]
house and health for people dude i could
live 15 years oh i know you without ever
working i was going to ask you there it
was so cheap i could live 15 years
easily i haven't really thought about it
exactly how much do you think it would
cost easily to like
for like rent
and and if you want to get a place it's
got to be cheaper than staying in
hostels right to actually get a place
because you can go long term
yeah that's what i mean that's what i've
i've just heard like
i don't know of course those flights are
a little expensive flights are expensive
but you don't say flights you take buses
how much everybody goes anywhere
did you have you ever stayed in a hotel
on these places because yeah so how much
is like a decent hotel
a night an okay place
is like
between like
25 and like
55.
but most of the time it's like it's like
20 or 25 we'd split hotel rooms for like
12 each
yeah well yeah well i mean even even 10
each even in san diego they're 200 a
night so yeah yeah to just be able to
cut it by four yeah but it's like it's
like it's fine whatever you get it's
like this is fine
it's not it's nothing good
and for something like good where it's
like oh this is comfortable
um have a your own nice shower
okay yeah maybe that's like 40 or 50
bucks
it's not terrible it's not terrible no
you can get it whenever you want
and then sometimes you can go like more
but 450 bucks will get it done i stayed
a decent nice one actually in uh in uh
chiang mai northern thailand i hooked up
finally once you had oh cause you got a
nice hotel you got to spring forward up
no it's gonna happen you're like we're
not gonna do this in the dorm i'm like i
have the money for a hotel room let's go
to a [ __ ] hotel room so you get it
and you just wasted the eight you spent
at the hostel but then you go get a 35
one but it was about that 35
nice place nice shower
okay we could sleep for a few hours i'm
surprised you went to hostels
that's they're
like i i've been to free hostels in
israel and were you really yeah then the
one in jerusalem like where they kick
you out or they want you to go
what'd you think of them
i mean they were they were nice it's
definitely okay but it's just
i i i i snore so i'm self-conscious
so i don't want to [ __ ] anybody's day up
yeah i can hear that
you know when you told me you were first
doing this thing at first i thought of
the pocket and uh
missed opportunities i mean
you've worked hard you've gotten a
couple good films
your movie's running on the airplane now
i saw it once in a plane get ahead of me
yeah yeah yeah so that's good i saw it
like one up over and i saw that scene i
did i was about to just watch that
that's the only way i watched it i just
see it on there i was like cool look at
it it's crazy it's crazy yeah it's
playing on airplanes and uh
and that's all i looked at it like that
at first
and then i looked at it as a
person who's lived here for 20 years
been lied to
yeah things
you know people this this this
and for one day they'd say you know what
i have the
the power to tell us all to suck my dick
i'm going to israel for six months to
learn how to write letters on the
[ __ ] wall and
yeah it's
so
peace of mind
in this business
is so [ __ ] important
and if you lost your mind at one time
and you've gotten it back
and all of a sudden things start to
rattle and roll for you again
you realize how happy you are that
you've gotten over that hump
that you didn't buy into it like people
like justin middleweight what's her name
got here she was crazy
uh the crazy girl then she went to vegas
and now you don't even hear about her
anymore shema no not shamer oh the other
girl
killed a crazy girl
the girl that dances the young girl bro
oh britney spears britney spears britney
spears got here
girl from louisiana she had alligators
in the back she didn't go crazy she
[ __ ] wised up man no no she wised up
but in the beginning yeah remember she
shaved the head yeah that's what i'm
talking about but what's his name she
figured it out she's like [ __ ] you
people but when you get your [ __ ]
anymore once you figure it out yeah get
out of here she shaved her head in front
of people you figure [ __ ] you this is
what you like you figure it out that
it's all up they're all blowing smoke up
your ass and everybody has a handout
and trying to make a dollar from you
nobody really has
your health
or your mental health and you could ari
tell me i'm lying to you i could look
you in the face yeah and say listen man
i only want to go out once a month they
don't give a [ __ ]
they'll call you three days later
it's [ __ ] crazy nobody gives a [ __ ]
lee it's [ __ ] crazy
you know you do they keep trying to talk
you into doing well and then they start
calling you on friday when you're on the
road finish the [ __ ] thing i said
when i'm ready i'll tell you i've got
nine we i got one
two you know i got one
two
two weeks and two weeks off
and i got a call the other day to do
radio
for july 16th the other day
like are you [ __ ] [ __ ] like they
sent me a list of [ __ ] what i wanted to
do and what i didn't want to do i go
first of all i have no idea what i want
to do that week
what the [ __ ] lisa act gets a show on
[ __ ] whatever and i got to be a
co-star already i don't [ __ ] know i
got to tell you what i want to do for
radio now
and you sit down i haven't even gotten
on a plane to this city
and all of a sudden somebody else is
like
i hate when i get i could be here monday
through [ __ ]
thursday morning and every day i got
three emails two of them from fleming's
steakhouse
the rest is one person i give a [ __ ]
about yeah
dawg i get on the plane thursday morning
yeah i get off the [ __ ] plane i look
at my emails i got four [ __ ] emails
from sponsors
who want to change that copy
i got 10 emails from [ __ ] the agency
what hotel do you want to stay at in
july or august it's [ __ ] june you
know questions that really don't matter
and why didn't you ask me
when i was in front of my [ __ ]
computer monday to wednesday you
couldn't [ __ ] ask me
so i understand man why you did it once
you were gone
i missed you like i said but i was
cheering for you i'm like [ __ ] it
he should just stay there to whatever
now let's say this netflix special comes
out this comes out worldwide yeah when
you go to worldwide you could walk into
a bar and go let them know i wish your
fee is in town wednesday night i'm
splitting the door with your 50 50 i'm
doing the show here yeah exactly even if
you get 50 people you don't give a [ __ ]
no i go play places yeah pay for the
hotel rooms yeah this is whatever
be able to sustain myself go see little
things that would be a [ __ ] great
adventure take leeway you haven't taped
it
yeah tape those little things into
looking bro who knows yeah who knows
what cmt will buy anymore can you
imagine you take lee with you and you go
to ten different asian countries and do
stand up for five of them and bring it
back and they go to a pitch meeting then
we don't get this show hold on one
second
hit it lee lee hits the button also
that's you and lee in the jungles of
bangkok and that night you're at a bar
shaking your [ __ ] butt and they're
like what the [ __ ] is this we're buying
this right now
they leave with you and but don't take
them ziplining because
jesus christ we broke this
break his some [ __ ] place before i'm
happy you're back brother i'm happy
you're healthy yeah you look healthy
you're not going to feel good man
not much processed food i think
really maybe
was your diet mostly rice way ricey
everything's over rice especially the
last like
forty five days at least you feel
anything different did you feel the carb
change or something maybe i just started
to shred down a little bit and then i
had too many beers in the early on and
then that got like chang weight let's
put on that chang wait how long did you
stay sober from marijuana though
i'll throw myanmar all to myanmar
all through myanmar and you felt great
then yeah and i honestly i had the last
piece of one thing and i uh when i last
i was like i'm leaving myanmar tomorrow
and i just had this
and i gave it to somebody [ __ ] buddy
i was like hey you're gonna be here
longer i'm not gonna take it across the
border
but like you know do it when it's time i
don't want to do it [ __ ] clear-headed
a little bit it's good to get clear yeah
it's good to drop everything yeah a full
month i didn't do it in chiang mai
i must have smoked in pie
over a month
over a month did you do any work
what do you what are you taught what
work oh you mean stand-up work anything
oh no you mean labor
no no no no like like did you do really
any writing any
any anything you would have to do here
or did you take everything off i ain't
no house servant
did i donate i can't imagine you picking
a rice in the fields did you talk you
didn't write a captain did you keep a
journal yeah i kept the journal daily
yeah after like the first like 10 12
days first it was just like a note or
two and then it was like every 10 12
days just full entry every day just like
kind of like remembering stuff
i don't know
taking stock in what you went through
you know just like oh yeah then that
happened yesterday that was cool
it's weird [ __ ] soccer matches with
people
little kids
it's fun man
so fun out there were you scared like
the first couple days at all or no yeah
hella scared
my plane stopped through san francisco
um
uh yeah real scared i didn't know what
to think i didn't know what to make of
those people
they seemed so different i thought
they're all gonna [ __ ] roll me
any places where you went where they
talked about isis or anything no no not
at all indonesia they had muslims but it
wasn't like that at all but they did
have bali bombs not too long ago
two bombs went off but i think that was
even before
or maybe since 9 11 but it wasn't the
latest one in the world it was like 10
years ago
maybe 2007
but like you know not not anymore than
any other place
what about the meet you ain't because
joey always yeah tortures me and says
i'm eating cat i really don't want to
eat cat there's full dog on one menu let
me explain how the wobble rooms work uh
it's like you know the pizza shelf where
just use points or slice and they warm
it up
so instead they have like slices of meat
either beef or chicken or fish or one
time dog and they have it chopped up and
cooked and it's in the window and they
don't heat it up at all though that's
whatever temperature is it just stays
there for for who knows how long
and then they just put that over hot
rice oh did you eat the dog i did not
eat the dog why because it was cold
yeah i'm not gonna try [ __ ] cold dog
the first time
did they tell you what type of dog it
was
would that made a difference like
there's so many out there before they
tell them what talking about yeah
if they send out a name that'd make it
feel bad
but there's like 20 like strays
everywhere there there's like fish
they're just stray dogs
they they need to eat meat
so they eat the [ __ ] stray dogs
and you see the dogs hanging upside down
like
you're going around
she fully told me it was chopped up like
what's that and i thought she said duck
and she kept correcting me
and saying dog
see at least they tell you
they tell you they're not just happening
yeah yeah yeah well they can't tell you
here
they can't tell you here because it's
against the law yeah there it's totally
fine but then since they've been doing
it for 2000 years they're not going to
stop killing dogs yeah so in the morning
that's why they leave for work early
they circle the neighborhood and there
you go they're sleeping dogs sure and
whatever they got
it all goes to the same recipe
you put a pigeon to a chewy dog would
you eat dog
if
if it was hot out of the oven i'm
talking like fresh juicy looking meat
over hot rice
delicious like home cooked like a meal
but at a restaurant
i mean steam's coming out of it you can
smell the [ __ ] delicious meat
i don't know all right jesus christ
dog's hard well that [ __ ] went to san
francisco and eating that was the only
meat on the menu
so not that there's nothing else to eat
but if you want to eat anything with
protein that's your only choice what
about there
what are the are the other options like
broccoli tofu
broccoli no not tofu no tofu no sandwich
i'll definitely eat broccoli just
broccoli yeah [ __ ] yeah i'll definitely
eat broccoli over dog sorry
just broccoli just plain old broccoli
and i i know it doesn't make any sense
just the same animal okay okay okay one
step further now one step further easy
easy one step further
what if now no broccoli okay
it's just just dog and rice oh yeah easy
just rice just rice okay okay well okay
okay okay
okay well i think the next step is we're
going to take away the rice
so then it's just dog that's your only
choice really for the meal today
for for a one day just one meal just one
meal did i eat yesterday you ate oh just
one meal yeah but wait but you ate like
early as yesterday and you didn't have
breakfast and it's already like
three or four p.m
and it's hot out of the oven and it's so
tender
what are you and there's rice there if
you want to use with the hog
oh they have all sorts of fresh spices
or just
flat fresh because it's just delicious
meat it's almost like a steak well you
don't need anything on it it's so it'll
melt in your mouth that's how that is
the only thing that deters me
from taking a trip to visit and hang out
want to eat dog no any of the hunger any
of that those menus lehigh
discuss this constantly i would die i'll
[ __ ] my dude that says oysters in
vietnam on the side of the road just
oysters and i'm like [ __ ] yeah put that
on the girl give me one of those give me
one of those orders
and i was fine i was so risking it dude
when i went to san francisco in 85 i met
mario uh harbor cubans yeah people who
got out in
in 79
they were the cubans that fidel emptied
the jail
and dumped on the united states sent
them to miami in austin
in miami murders went up because these
people were savages
but not to
deter this
i met a kid
and he was telling me how the whole
thing had gone down
at that time in san francisco in 85
san francisco and uh
and the tenderloin had like a two block
cuban community
yeah of all cubans that came over in 79.
now they had developed and they still
weren't getting jobs and they were on
the streets they ran like two streets
they sold nickel bags they sold fake ids
they bought hot travelers checks [ __ ]
like that they didn't really they
weren't big time criminals nothing but
since i could speak english
i could help them
so i became tight with them and there
was one kid in particular i started
talking to
and i go so how did it go down he told
me that there was some thing and
he was a
a civil engineer this kid i met him
selling nickel bags and blow
and i asked him what did you do because
that's when i started getting this the
history from these people yeah and i
asked him what did you do in cube when
he told me what he was and in my mind
i'm like how can you be a civil engineer
and you're out here selling [ __ ] coke
like i didn't ask him this
but he's telling me all these stories
and then he started telling me a story
about how
the biggest i go was it easy to get on a
boat and he goes the boat and everything
was easy
it was the paperwork
that was hard you had to go to the
embassy
and he goes listen bro
for six days
you couldn't get off the line
people were [ __ ] and pissing
in bags and water bottles
so uh
he goes and he told me a graphic [ __ ]
story about
a guy that had a [ __ ] dog
and the people kept telling him listen
man that dog is looking mighty tasty
the kid's like please he's my dog and
they're like listen we haven't eaten
their names
and they started messing with the kid
messing with the kid kids started crying
some guy came took the dog from took the
dog and broke the dog's neck right now
oh jesus where is this well where the
[ __ ] in havana during the embassy
he goes the guy slit the dog open
three or four cubans came over right in
front of the kid they put bricks down
and they started barbecuing the [ __ ]
dog what right on the [ __ ] grill they
were counting like they were like there
was no food you were on a line for four
days and you couldn't get off the line
and there's a kid with a [ __ ] dog
where's that happening right now like no
no no it's happening i mean this is what
happened in cuba
was in 1979 was that fidel no
stick it up 19 said just yahoo google
havana 19th century muriel harbor
situation and let's just read on what
happened right no no these cubans were
and they were all prisoners of
castro people who
oppose a certain government like if you
didn't go to work one day if you played
zeppelin
right you weren't the opposition really
castro was throwing you in jail for
being jewish
because he didn't trust you because on
that day
he didn't trust [ __ ] jews right so
now you're in jail for 20 [ __ ] years
he let those people out and those people
were [ __ ] pissed
and they were full
fledged criminals like here you go to a
jail
and you get a bed and a cot and
life is okay three squares there yeah
that's every minute from zell
you and lee could be brothers and i'm in
the cell
and every morning instead of three
breakfast is coming in one comes in
guess what ari
we're fighting for that [ __ ] egg oh
yeah you know that's that's
so we can either fight and kill each
other or we can split the breakfast in
three
either way we're gonna starve
they make you an animal in those jails
but he was telling me that story how
they kept telling the kid kid that dog
is looking mighty good
and the kid's like come on you guys are
silly you know so that's like two days
later like kid that dog's gotta go
yeah it obviously seems [ __ ] up but if
i was put in that situation like it
happened not eating for days then you
would date anyone yeah honey
would you enjoy it
after your eighth ninth tenth eleventh
time trying it i was thinking
deliciously seasoned that if it was
gonna be anyone to cook dog like having
it be cubans it probably was better hmm
pressed sandwiches
i was gonna see like actual spices as
opposed to just like
so i don't want anything just salt and
pepper it needs to be spicy can you blow
that up a little bit the front line the
top one look what it says there
it says
ten thousand cubans tried to get a sound
by taking refuge on the peruvian embassy
the cuban government announced anyone
who wanted to go
could do so
the ensuing mass immigration organized
by cuban americans with the agreement of
president fidel castro a revenue refugee
uh cuban general see there was it was
discovered
response to the immigrants and then it
was discovered that a number of refugees
had been released from cuban jails
mental health facilities
the mario boatlift was ended by mutual
agreement between the two governments
and late october 1980 after as many 125
cubans
25 000 cubans
had reached florida that was a complete
[ __ ]
it was more like 200 000. oh really it
was [ __ ] crazy was people just coming
over on rafts from cuba it was 125 000
let's let me tell you what it became
then it became
what anything becomes
immigrants 125 000 should attack the
shores on rafts yep no no no speed boats
oh really did you get on the left
because you would call me and go pops
you would call me and go joey
i i'm done i'm not sitting here fidel
opened up the jails
get me out of here where are you i'm in
camaraway on the eastern coast there's a
boat thing called whatever i'll be here
at this number and you would sit by that
[ __ ] pay phone
and play phone tag with me and i would
have to go to miami
rent the boat and make sure we get the
cube on the boat to where you are
and then bring the boat back that worked
for a few days
and then people started saying ari come
on give me five thousand i'll take you
to go get lee
and once i got lee he i get you
and i said i'll shoot you in the [ __ ]
head
of what if you don't give me an extra
ten thousand dollars oh no what's that
lee
this is the breakdown of what they're
saying came per month
from april 21st they had almost eight
thousand
and then it was ninety thousand
twenty thousand and this is seventy nine
uh i believe so yeah this is seventy
nine
twenty thousand what
who had people from cuba
to miami wow
it was it was crazy hitting the shores
hitting the shoes illegal or legal legal
legal because we were like hey anybody
wants in right right fidel is letting
them in all the prisoners would like i'm
sorry
he opened up his presence his mental
institutions and he let off the [ __ ]
worst criminals everybody tangles up
with good people oh you want people over
there go ahead here's a doctor and stuff
and uh wow yeah we learned the big lie
everybody learned the big i don't even
know why we're talking about it but
that's what had happened and it's crazy
because you see
when you see scarface and they're on the
bus
he chastises him for
not telling the story right that he was
in a mental institution in cuba do you
remember that scene he's like tell him
you were i told you to tell him
you want an institution
yeah another sanitarium
and he goes no no you told me to tell
him i was in the sanitary you
told
know
to tell him you're a tv
and you were in or whatever
and he goes you should have shut your
mouth they would have thought you were a
horse
it's all right so july 18th
double [ __ ] cd special event double
special double special yeah and uh on
netflix called double negative thanks
first off i'm happy you're back thank
you i'm happy you're at the store it's
good to see you thank you very much had
a nice time at dinner was very good
wasn't it um oh yeah man that that
belonged the ace yeah
yeah [ __ ] good
you sat there with a little coke spoon
pouring parmesan cheese i felt like
david bowie of the bolognese [ __ ]
movie sprinkle sprinkle sprinkle just
pickles pickles you just don't mind
chilling until the 23rd challenge no
dates nowhere
are you doing you're back in new york
you're not going to ever say what are
you doing at skank fest i don't know i'm
judging naked roast okay
um and
who's doing the naked roast
a bunch of people women too yeah women
too yeah everybody's up there you doing
it i'm judging and naked yeah of course
obviously tremendous sorry yeah
it never ends with you
my balls are too saggy that's why it's
great you got the shots and everything
just in case
you step on a nail with [ __ ] fungi
nailing it
and what else you got that's it you know
taking this i'm doing the joker's cruise
hanging out with those guys in november
yeah i'm taking everything that's the
joker's cruise you know sal and those
guys
and when do you live where do you leave
from new orleans
and where do you go i don't know some
place
i don't know it's a crew it's five five
days okay
i've never done one before living the
life of riley yeah just about to hang
out by a lounge chair
well you know me though you're my
brother yeah i wish you nothing but luck
no matter where you go
you're always family to the podcast and
we're just happy to have you yeah i'm
just happy to stay home for a little
while
do [ __ ] all
right
you know what man what
right now in comedy you're in the right
to do whatever the [ __ ] you want to and
that's why i tell people all the time
the other day people were comparing a
bunch of things and said you know what
man i had to be honest with you
wow
i don't even think about that stuff well
i don't even think about any of that
stuff
about what i could be doing maybe i
should be doing this i'm very happy
doing what i'm doing
if i was supposed to be somebody else i
wouldn't end up being somebody else do
you know what i'm saying yeah
like enough enough with the [ __ ] uh
pattern they had for comics all through
the years
that was a very much take a comic
burn them out and then [ __ ] toss them
to the side now the guy wakes up one day
when he's 50. he's got no resume
and he's walking around town they can't
even get spots at the economy store yeah
you've seen that right before a bunch of
times a bunch of times
so now we're because of things like the
podcast and we have our own vehicles we
don't fall into that trap man
i'm doing what i want to be doing i'm
doing a podcasting stand up
that's all i want to be doing at this
point if you write a role for me and
it's cool just to cover my insurance i'm
there if you put me through a bunch of
hoops if i got to drive to [ __ ]
riverside
and put suntan lotion on you're in no
[ __ ] danger if you're not shooting a
mile away you're in no [ __ ] danger
anymore i don't want to shoot nothing
more if it's going to make your [ __ ]
worse
where they're like that's half finished
and they were like all right it's good
enough come on you're like no no no
you know it's there
i'm interested in doing something
different i would love to recur on a tv
show right now you really yeah what kind
of tv show comparative song
comedy great hospital that one that one
show would you do that that uh
children's hospital
oh yeah he would do that yeah
well it's 15 15 minutes yeah so there's
not much to do on those two days a week
i would like to recur on something
that i shot at cbs radford yeah that the
people knew me
oh a lot it was like yeah
that the people knew me like like i knew
him from the store from 15 years oh yeah
yeah that'd be fun they come up to me
and then they go listen can we talk to
you in the kitchen at the store and
you're like yeah what's up
we got a show on cbs thursday nights at
8 30.
we my partner and i have discussed it we
talked to the brass at cbs
we got you a little gig six weeks or six
weeks six seven episodes we'll pay you a
little extra
joey
we can't have the reefer in the
periscope
the [ __ ] the little jewish kid with
you eating those [ __ ] stars and that
you don't say
you know what i'd take but they dug me
like that and i looked at them and said
what if
what if on the way to the studio i
bumped into somebody and took a hit of
that joint would that be cool we'd
accept that you know yeah
and can you shoot me out quick because
after three hours i gotta smoke dope
we're gonna shoot you out first
you know i would consider doing it if
it's a friend of mine and he understands
and he knows like listen bro when do you
have to be out of here by
your family you hired me you're paying
me
between you and i
i don't have to be out of here until
wednesday of midnight
because all i need is three hours of
sleep i get on a [ __ ] plane yeah and
i'll sleep when i get to the hotel room
there for two hours it's an 8 30 show on
a thursday night it's only one show
you eat a few stars you come back to
your hotel room you wake up you do radio
friday morning you tip top magoo you eat
breakfast you come back you take another
nap till two
you write a little bit you go to the gym
and you do your two shows and that's
your friday night seriously
if you came to me with an interesting
show yeah that we could do for netflix
or
something that people would really watch
something cool something cool
we're gonna have some nice shoots but
you know what brother it's good to have
you around i'm gonna give you a big
trailer you could do whatever the [ __ ]
you want
i mean don't shoot heroin yeah even as i
am but i'm gonna smell a little take a
walk like a professional i'm not gonna
be mad at you i know you work good with
you those type of things yeah yeah
but if i'm gonna go to cbs and they're
just gonna watch me and
i can't have weed on my breath like
biggie in 85 95 and now
i'm not interested anymore i'm too old
it's got to be loose
i got to do one of your takes i got to
do one of the producer's takes i'm going
to do one of my takes what do you mean
like if we're going to shoot this thing
for you the right way if it's going to
be comedy yeah give me the respect to
give me one take
let me tell your lines my way all right
right right i'm going to do one for lee
i'm going to do one for you because it's
your [ __ ] show this how you want it
but i have an idea can we want to win
one one time like that ari and you're
gonna go you know what joey i like that
just say the first two words and cut
that out boom and also we all
collaborated everybody's happy like i'm
one of those guys i'm yeah yeah but
don't sit there and go she just came
over joey and said you have to say was
harry was the what's the difference i
know
but this is cbs and
you know what i'm saying i don't wanna i
don't want to do that i'm too old yeah
but someone i like ifc
yeah you know and i hate when people go
well nobody watches if he gives a [ __ ]
nobody watches anything yeah nobody
really watches anything yeah so they let
you go and do whatever you want yeah
there's so much vast entertainment out
there at your fingertips places that
people put everything in the checklist
and they might get to you yeah because
every week they're they're they're
budget watching yeah what are they doing
they're binge watching yeah from friday
to [ __ ] sunday budget watching yeah
then it's over in no time yeah so by the
time they get to you there is so much
content available to you now yeah with
all without money with or without cable
you have so much content available to
you now that now you're over stimulated
you can't watch everything that's coming
out you know i was reading that they're
having a dismal summer
in [ __ ] uh
in uh show business to some like if it
wasn't for wonder woman the numbers were
staggering sure what did most americans
do last friday lee
what do you think [ __ ] sixty percent
of americans did last friday they stayed
in
the waters probably and watch what oh
this is the house of cards what did you
say uh orange is the new purple also got
released yeah so most people ask me
if house of cards came out friday and
[ __ ] orange is the new purple came
outside black yeah black is the new
purple yeah
what movie are you gonna go [ __ ] see
for 35 hours with your girlfriend black
purple no you're not you're gonna stay
home and watch netflix all right there
ain't no movie
this week unless you watch one there's a
new season of that yeah i don't know i
don't watch that show but to americans
yeah i'm telling you right now that most
americans go
do i really want to go see this movie at
the movie theater for 17.50 a piece 15
for parking
popcorn dinner at the japanese
restaurant or we could just order a
[ __ ] pizza and get a bottle of wine
[ __ ] suck
eight episodes orange is the new purple
dude
the last two weeks was f is for family
and then house of cards yeah i gotta get
off yeah how are you gonna [ __ ] go
give me a bottle of water eight dollars
a month please
i'm begging you
listen to this
there's nothing on it i'm gonna give you
how much how much tv did you watch or
did you try to avoid staying [ __ ]
zero man the first night there turned on
the tv never again
three and a half months
oh no
oh
you know man the good thing was you went
there
to take a break from everything and you
took a break from it yeah i got so
[ __ ] rested nothing to do no
responsibility no responsibility
whatsoever i know where i go wherever
the [ __ ] you want to go i know where i
put your leather so if one day you want
to see it but it's funny
i could tell in the letter that you were
excited about starting over again like
your character yeah like you were done
and like that was interesting line that
you're staying at hostels and in the
back of my mind
i know you could stay in the motel 6 in
any [ __ ] city in the nation yeah but
for some reason you wanted to pay your
dues you wanted to be a human being
again you know what i'm saying yeah you
just wanted to do things to start over
and i got it i got it after that i was
like ah this [ __ ] normal thing you
know yeah yeah we're going to just walk
in christ
some [ __ ] yeah man we're all going
here take a picture move on please to
here
oh brother i'm happy you're back i'm
happy you put the special together in
netflix yeah it's pretty funny cool man
that's the way i wanted it like a double
thing together you know where it's like
one ends start watching the next one or
take a break for a day but it's like
you'll see they're both connected sort
of to each other
it's [ __ ] good and you shot them both
in cap city in austin
yeah
yeah
yeah
good i'm happy yeah that's a great place
we rebuilt the stage i'm happy that bond
got to here brother oh my god yeah that
first dog [ __ ] killed you i heard i'm
telling you i'm happy you're back i'm
happy you're smoking some california
buds
do not forget people this thursday night
uncle joey working out with uncle joey
pasadena at the ice house 8
30
and then the 23rd and 24th
i will be at levee town
governors two shows friday
two shows saturday in and out no drama
you know just working at baby boy and
that's it i want to thank uh ari for
coming back on but before i get already
off here i got to tell you people
something tell us
father's day's around the corner
tushy.com
hellotushi.com you know why because
bidets are back you don't have to walk
around the summer's coming humidity is
lurking around the corner you know what
that means swamp ass swamp bags
hemorrhoids bacteria nobody wants that
you're sitting there all day it's a
[ __ ] nightmare telemark the sweat
next to you just know about the
hemorrhoids
you can't sit down it's amazing you know
why
that's why you don't have a bidet you
try to rub that filthy [ __ ] ass with
old [ __ ] tree
that they got from communist china
somewhere that got bombarded with
chemicals and then you wonder why your
[ __ ] looks like a [ __ ] like it got
shot in what
a lego aleppo your [ __ ] looks like
aleppo you understand me you know why
you [ __ ] looks it smells like aleppo
hellotushy.com
a portable bidet what does that mean
portable where portable that you would
take with you on the road you could you
absolutely could if you could take it on
the road or take it from your mother's
bedroom but that's what you really do
better you go to different rooms
different bathrooms yeah you usually get
a big day okay it's attached to the
floor you need certain plumbing with
this you attach it to your toilet
you can attach it within seven minutes
you can be sitting on a thing getting
water
a bunch up there yes you did [ __ ]
cold hose butt spray man and does it
change your life but it does
go it was fine i think they sort of did
because i didn't bleed i stopped [ __ ]
bleeding animals this is what i'm saying
to you i know for a fact and as soon as
i got back it started up again
cleanliness is next to godliness you got
to keep that muffler clean muffler
it's dirty but that's all over cause
hello tushy is back get yourself a
portable bidet attached to your toilet
no more swamp ass your dad's ass don't
smell your mom's ass don't smell
everybody's walking around tip top magoo
fresh and the best thing is you got a
90-day warranty if something happens but
then the summer's over you won't even
need it anything's gonna happen yes you
do nothing's gonna happen let me tell
you something even in the winter once
you get addicted to hello douchey you'll
understand why i can help you up that's
going to warm up the water it could warm
up you could do whatever
can you warm it up please talk they have
a heart they have a hot one but i only i
have the one that's only cold i love how
does it feel what do you think it starts
my day it's it's amazing
like let's say you took a shower
you took a shower you walked around new
york
it gets a little swampy back there but
you don't have time to take another
shower
bam oh that's all you need that's all
you need to do your balls while you're
there i have another one back a little
bit that's a little
soap a little bit
you clean your nuts you throw some soap
above because you know with his hair it
gets all sweaty
hellotushy.com right
always go on a date with confidence your
helmet won't smell your [ __ ] won't
smell you know why
hello tushy engineering go to
hellotushy.com right now and press in
hellotushy.com church boom and get 10
off number two
i love them i use their products every
day whether it's the hemp protein the
chocolate the cacao or
look at how the shroom tech sport i'm on
it every day without it you understand
me they also have kettlebells and steel
bars and
mazes and all that fun stuff but i can
only help you and tell you for sure
about the supplements sure i have their
kettlebells and i have their steel bars
but i can't get you any discount on them
as far as alpha brain it's got a
money-back
guarantee you try if it doesn't make you
sharp and improve your memory
listen to me and improve your focus
we'll give you your money back we don't
even want the product that's how much we
believe in alpha brain from there you're
looking for protein you're looking for
pure protein easy digestible protein
boom
hem force cacao
[ __ ] it taste it's the best tasting
protein out there a couple ice cubes
some water mix it up throw banana in
there it's heaven okay they also have
the acai vanilla flavor
also the new mood also the shroom tech
sport and the shroom tech immune listen
i can sit here for hours or you can just
go to onit.com right now and take a look
at all the great supplements from mct
oil i mean they got it all do me a favor
on the way out as you're checking out go
to the box and press in church boom and
get 10 off delivered right to your house
okay these are my two favorite people in
the world again on it.com and
hellotushy.com ari yes sir your family
thank you very much for going
getting your head together coming back
now you know you definitely don't want
to be in you're really getting the [ __ ]
out of here so i also applaud you for
that i love you today
thank you for coming on this show yeah
stay black and stay beautiful lee how
you feeling see
you ate 10 stars
plus the other thing and look you're
fine yeah you're fine
it's on your head
this is what i say
all the time you defeat yourself on your
own you're like the girl who does anal
and dude
you break down i can do but i just don't
want to do it every night joey listen
you don't do this every night do you he
wants me to know five nights a week no
no no he won six maybe six and a half
years i'm gonna take two nights off
because you need to refresh
but the other two nights what happens is
he goes over there on wednesday and he
gets all [ __ ] up thursday friday
saturday she smacks them around
around
tells them what food they're gonna eat
and [ __ ] yeah tells them he can't eat
stars he's like 400. what are you
talking about oh really you're going to
[ __ ] do that no i don't know
no no no be honest
he's dead he passes out he orders pizza
when did you go joey from from going
from where we used to eat 50
milligrams it was 50 milligrams we each
have and it would [ __ ] put us on the
moon listen as humans we have to evolve
i think
he said that you know oh my gosh as
humans we need to evolve only 50
milligrams full
keep your tones down what tolerance you
got to build it up you got to be
prepared if you go over i'm so sorry if
you're obviously you live in california
jesus christ
i read that challenge man that was that
i made that challenge that was that
rigatoni yeah it was jesus christ i made
my dad's chilling how was it it was so
good it was exactly like i remembered it
really from the recipe so you made it
right to precise for it dude it came out
like at first i was like oh it's little
and then i left the top off for like
four or five minutes it could shield up
and i was like perfect consistency now
now man where are you supposed to eat
that what how when no it was winter time
it's just warm it's just warm
yeah you can let overflow under your
brisket and then like eat that with it
sort of dip sort of a savory dip
oh man it's so good man i'm gonna make
it in new york so what is it i've
already decided it's chunked
what do you mean you can't say it like
that
what is it what is it beans a lot of
beans some barley potatoes but it's like
slow slow cooked 18 hours are you
sephardic
no man chillin's [ __ ] i don't know
where it gets cold sephardic is like
yeah
so far they're good
dirt shoes
[Laughter]
jungle juice
thank you again buddy have a great week
god bless you know i love you at all my
are you yeah i love you too you're the
last it's nice seeing you i'm glad yeah
see your face
we got a little dinner and stuff don't
forget thursday night the ice house
don't next work
the 23rd and 24th ally long island
governor's [ __ ] i'll see you
[ __ ] wednesday night stay black
uncle joey lee syed and my main man
laurie sofia
[Applause]
[Music]
feliciado
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
food
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
hey
[Music]
okay
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
hey
[Music]
you